تخوض القوات الأوكرانية
معارك ضارية لاستعادة الأراضي في
الجنوب والشرق ، وتخوض بعض
المعارك الأكثر خطورة في الحرب الروسية في
أوكرانيا في السماء
على الرغم من أن فريد بلانكتون يوضح لنا ما هو على
المحك بالنسبة للطيارين المقاتلين الذين يقفون وراء
الضوابط
الأوكرانية.  -25 طائرة هجومية
هدفها مهاجمة المواقع الروسية
رغم كل الصعاب سلاح الجو الأوكراني لا يزال
في طيار القتال
يقول لي أليكسي هل تساعد
القوات البرية الآن كثيرًا في الجنوب
من خلال عملية هجوم مضاد.
مهمة خطيرة للغاية
خاصة بالنسبة لطائرة الهجوم على الخطوط الأمامية ،
الآسات الأوكرانية التي تحاول إبقاء
الدفاعات الجوية الروسية غير متوازنة ، فقد فقدنا العديد من
الطيارين الشباب من لواءنا ، وهذا
علمنا أن نغير شيئًا ما ، ونحاول يومًا بعد
يوم عدم الطيران كما كان
بالأمس
تقول كييف إنها مضادة-  الهجوم
يتقدم ،
المعارك صعبة ومكاسب يصعب
تحقيقها من خلال
أكبر تهديد تقول أوكرانيا إن
القوة الجوية الروسية هذا الفيديو الذي يزعم أنه يظهر
طائرة هليكوبتر قتالية روسية تقلع
مركبة أوكرانية
[موسيقى]
يقول الأوكرانيون إن طائرات اعتراضية روسية
مثل Su-35 المتقدمة  غالبًا ما
توقف طائرات MiG-29 القديمة عن
العمل بالقرب من الخطوط الأمامية ، حيث أخبرني
طيار MiG-29 الذي طلب منا إخفاء
وجهه واستخدام عصير إشارة المكالمة فقط أنه
يمكنك أن تكون مثل المنشق ولكن
بدون جهاز مناسب يمكنك '  للفوز بهذه
الطائرة ، يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم بحاجة إلى طائرات
F-16 من الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
لتسوية ساحة اللعب والاستفادة الكاملة من
الصواريخ التي يتم إطلاقها من الجو والتي
قدمتها لهم الولايات المتحدة بالفعل
بين مهام الحرب الضريبية التي
يتعلم فيها الطيارون بالفعل أساسيات
F-16 على أمل أن يتمكنوا من
التحليق بها في المستقبل يحاولون
تحسين مهاراتنا في اللغة الإنجليزية ، فنحن نطير
بمحاكيات لذلك في الوقت الحالي نحب
المحاكاة المرتجلة لطائرة F-16 تقريبًا على
جميع القواعد التي
يقول الطيارون عنها  إنهم مسألة
حياة أو
معدل تغذية للوفاة بين الطيارين القتاليين
مرتفعًا للغاية ،
قُتل قائد سرب أليكسي ورجل طياره في القتال ، كما يقول عندما
ترى انفجار
المغص
من عينيك في الوقت الفعلي
[موسيقى] ،
إنه لصدمة
إنها صورة مروعة ، نعم ،
والصعوبة حقًا في هذه الحالة هي
كيفية
الجلوس في الطائرة مرارًا
وتكرارًا ،
ولكن عندما تأتي المكالمة يقولون إنهم
سيكونون جاهزين ويعودون
إلى المقعد  الجبهة الروسية
كما في سي إن إن كييف